[Musique]
que la fête commence
la frime
certains noël c'est kate pierce j'étais
super sage cette année jeudi quelques
gros mots de temps en temps mais c'est
seulement quand mon frère teddy se moque
de moi que je fais tant qu'expert mon
sang-froid arrête tu m'as la casse est
pas grave alors au moins 20 ans de toute
façon je les travaille et c'est le soir
de noël maman tu vas rester ici avec ma
soeur on devrait faire une vidéo
peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir le père
d'un homme entier et est toujours pas au
courant c'est vrai personne il n'a
jamais vu le perdre au témoin que tu es
en train de filmer
tu réalises à quel point c'est
extraordinaire il faut que je regarde ça
de plus près quel poids lourd quoi
tu crois qu'il nous a vus j'ai pas
l'impression
je viens t'asseoir
en chair et en os une celui parents
quittent et à korhogo
je ne fais pas c'est un mythe l'esprit
de noël est déjà descendu à 35% la
moitié du continent on aura passé cas de
sarah une poignée de gamins aura pas de
cadeau c'est pas la fin du monde riche
on peut joindre à elles pour leur
rappeler à quel point ils peuvent être
bien qu'ayant walid était devenu
tellement ou vieille vois ce que je veux
dire tu es devenue une femme mais coûte
wendy n'a besoin d'être conduit au
centre-ville et pas prendre un ibère tu
crois que je peux payer le chauffeur
avec ça imagine l'efficacité qu'on
aurait en s'y mettant à 3 doit pouvoir
marcher il faut que je rassemble mais
rennes comme est plus vrai quand même
que j'appelle les mutants je crois que
peu une autre et non répéter
vous pouvez leur ai parlé peut-être que
je pourrai sauver non
[Musique]
or est affreux
on a moins d'une heure avant le lever du
jour tu la fête commence
j'ai une voiture tu peux pas faire un
détour de jedi et nous débarrasser des
flics je suis le père noël tony baiona
occupants danse et rigoler pour ce soir
tu les entends
ross départ là
pourquoi faut-il qu'il continue à me
représenter comme ça franchement est ce
que mes fesses ont l'air aussi groupe